Turner chair of the energy transitions commission and former chair of the
financial services authority,
and first chair of the UK climate change committee and a former director general
of the CBI.
And also I should point out he played a leading role in the redesign of global
banking regulation following the 2008 financial crisis.
And he's author of between debt and the devil money credit and fixing global
finance. Let's hear from our first speaker against the motion Adair Turner.
[Inaudible].
The debate this evening is not about whether climate change is a potentially
catastrophic threat to humanity,
but about how we effectively deal with it.
George has described some of the reasons why we have to act fast.
He's talked about the Arctic sea ice,
the dangers of tipping points with the methane release, the loss of corals,
the danger to food supplies.
And I'm not going to repeat or expand on that further because Tony and I
completely agree with that point.
We are facing a potential disaster and we have left it dangerously
late to take the action that can deal with it.
The international panel on climate change says that we must limit global
warming to 1.5 degree centigrade above pre-industrial
levels. And to do that,
we will have to reduce the emissions from industry buildings,
transport,
and agriculture to zero by around mid century.
And I mean, real zero,
not a pretend zero in which we go on consuming large
amounts of fossil fuels,
but tell ourselves that we've bought some offsets via some reforestation
somewhere else in the world. So the objective is clear,
get emissions to zero by around mid century.
The question is how to get there one way might be
to reject. So as George's has suggested the very idea of capitalist material
prosperity growth, and there's certainly a role for that,
at least in already developed rich countries,
all of us can.
And I think ideally should cut our carbon footprints by using public
transport,
by walking or bicycling by reducing avoidable flights or by reducing
or eliminating red meat consumption,
spending our income instead on the many forms of capitalist product
entertainment, high quality restaurant meals,
things which are intensive in design,
which do not require more material goods and energy
to support them.
But I think we have to be realistic about the limits of that change our
lifestyle approach in major city centers.
We can largely live without cars and our cities will be much nicer places
when we do that.
But you can't do without a car in the small towns of rural France and the
GLA shown red,
yellow vest movement shows what happens if a government ignores that reality.
And in India,
where I have spent the last three days discussing how to decarbonize the Indian
economy, there are 1.3,
5 billion people currently using about one third of the
energy per capita,
which we use and who want in future to enjoy Western middle-class
standards of living.
And that will require more energy in their transport systems in air
conditioning systems,
which for understandable reasons are growing rapidly and embedded in the
consumer goods they buy. And I have to say to George,
that if I turned up on Monday and told the Indians people that I was
dealing with,
that was the answer was that they were not going to have the standards of living
that everybody in this room has, the conversation would have ended.
At that point.
So while lifestyle change has a role,
the main route to radical emissions reductions must be to use
energy more efficiently and to use only zero carbon forms of energy.
And the good news is that it is undoubtedly technically possible to get to
net zero by that route. And we broadly know how to do it.
We need to electrify as much of the economy as possible,
increasing total global electricity supply about four or
five times. And all of that electricity must be zero carbon.
And that's possible because the sun shines down on earth each
day,
8,000 times as much energy as total human
energy demand and the cost of solar electricity of taking
those photons and turn them into electricity has fallen over
85% in the last 10 years.
So while George talked about absolute limits to material supply,
actually in relation to clean energy, once we fixed the technology,
there is no limit to the amount of clean energy that we can capture and
enjoy. We also need to use hydrogen in multiple applications.
We can use it for instance, to decarbonize our steel production,
to decarbonize our shipping.
And we must make that hydrogen in a zero carbon fashion,
but you can do that by electrolysis using zero carbon electricity,
all of that will require investments,
which if you add them up and think about them in trillions of dollars or
trillions of pounds seem very large,
but actually as a percentage of the total global economy are relatively small
one or 2% and totally affordable. So let's be clear.
We can build a zero carbon economy while supporting growth still
countries, and the cost are surprisingly small.
And the best way to do that is not to reject capitalism,
but to regulate tax and direct capitalist activity while still using
private enterprise incentives and market competition help get there at
least cost.
And what that it means is that we need to have strong policies to force
capitalism, to do what we want it to do while leaving it,
to decide the details of how we get there. We could,
and we should ban all sales of internal combustion engines from,
let us say 2030,
but we should lend leave it to competing capitalist firms driven by the profit
motive to work out how to build electric vehicles in the most
efficient fashion. And I believe that we should ban all plastic incineration,
all plastic exports and all plastic sent to landfill by,
at the very latest 2025 and impose a carbon price on fossil fuel
inputs into new plastics production.
But we should then leave it to private enterprise to determine the precise mix
of mechanical or chemical recycling technologies, which we know exist,
and which could enable us to continue using plastics in many applications,
but in a zero carbon fashion.
Now right-wing ideologues will of course argue that if you regulate and tax
capitalism in this fashion,
it's no longer capitalism at all that the only capitalism possible is the ultra
free market, totally unregulated capitalism beloved by people like Donald Trump.
But that is nonsense because capitalism can come in many different forms and we
can choose the form. We want capitalism.
And here I agree with George means essentially a system in which most,
but not all,
not necessarily all of the means of production distribution exchange are owned
by private enterprise competing in markets to make profit and
capitalism can flourish and deliver benefits for humanity, even if,
and indeed precisely because it is tightly regulated and
appropriately taxed.
Indeed capitalism was most successful in delivering prosperity to the many,
not just the few when in the 1950s and sixties,
it was combined with very tight regulation of the financial sector with a
significant role for state-owned enterprises in some specific sectors of the
economy. And with top marginal tax rates far above current levels,
but nobody doubted that Germany,
Britain and America in the 1950s and sixties were capitalist economies
delivering both more rapid growth and far better environmental
results than the non-capitalist economies of Russia.
Eastern Europe three weeks ago,
presented a fascinating TV documentary called apocalypse cow
in it. He argued that the stock climate collapse,
we must radically reduce the role of land intensive agriculture.
And I agreed almost entirely with his arguments like George.
I think we are probably on the cusp of a technological revolution,
which will enable us to continue if we want to enjoy the taste of red meat,
but produced in a synthetic fashion,
which does not involve destructive deforestation nor terrible lives for
sentient beings.
And to illustrate that exciting technological potential George flew,
and he admitted this was breaking his normal rules.
He flew to Finland to visit a company called solar foods,
which is developing synthetic ways of producing carbohydrates,
which we can then either consume directly or use as feed stock for synthetic
meats. So what type of company is solar foods?
Well,
it's a private capitalist company raising money from
private investors who will expect a good return on their risky investment.
And while saga foods managers, undoubtedly want to do good for the world,
they own their investors may well also be motivated by the fact that if they
succeed, they will make good money.
I think we must embrace the innovative potential of capitalism even while
constraining it, taxing it,
regulating it and pointing it in the right direction. And if, instead,
we try to abolish capitalism.
I fear we will not stop climate catastrophe, but make it more likely.
[Inaudible].